Transcription: Melissa Munns
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Connaissez-vous vraiment votre identité ?
Lorsque vous vous réveillez le matin
et que vous vous regardez dans le miroir,
savez-vous qui vous ête
et ce pourquoi vous êtes fait ?
Pour être honnête,
je n’ai jamais vraiment su qui j’étais.
Je suis d’origine libanaise,
née au Sénégal
comme le sont mes parents,
comme l’étaient leurs parents avant eux.
La Téranga m’a vu naître,
mais c’est le pays des hommes intègres
qui a fait de moi ce que je suis.
Je suis arrivée au Burkina Faso
à l’âge de trois ans
et j’ai eu une merveilleuse enfance.
J’ai eu cette chance incroyable de pouvoir
grandir entourée de cultures différentes,
car c’est ce que représente
le Burkina Faso à mes yeux :
une terre d’accueil,
d’amour et de tolérance.
Mais au fur et à mesure que j’ai grandi,
des questions au fond de moi
sont restées sans réponse.
Qui étais-je réellement ?
Parmi toute cette mixité qui m’entourait
et qui me représentait, qui étais-je ?
Une Libanaise ?
Peut-être, mais une Libanaise
qui ne connaît pas sa culture,
qui ne connaît pas son pays
et qui ne parle d’ailleurs pas la langue.
Une Africaine ?
En tout cas, je me suis toujours
considérée telle quelle.
Mais pourtant, je suis blanche.
Je me rappelle,
quand on était petit à l’école française,
on avait l’habitude
d’organiser chaque  année
des journées de la francophonie.
Vous savez, ces journées
où chaque élève doit venir habillé
avec sa tenue traditionnelle
et le drapeau de son pays.
Et moi, chaque année, je venais
avec mon drapeau sénégalais.
J'étais fière et tous mes amis burkinabés
et africains se moquaient de moi.
« Ma Sarah, ma Sarah,
tu n’es pas africaine. »
Alors tout ça a fait que j’ai grandi
avec une certaine révolte en moi
et ces questionnements.
Qui suis-je ?
Qui suis-je et où est ma place ?
Je pense que la période de ma vie
qui a le plus marqué
ce désir intense d’identité,
cette recherche constante d’identité,
ça a été toute la période de ma vingtaine.
À 18 ans, je me suis envolée
pour Montréal pour les études
et toute la durée de mon séjour là-bas,
je n’ai jamais compris à quel point
on pouvait accepter d’être formaté
à un système qui ne nous imposait
qu’un seul modèle de réussite.
Et pourtant, tout le monde
autour de moi avait trouvé sa voie.
Parce que je n’ai plus peur
de le dire aujourd’hui ;
mais les études ont été
un véritable fiasco pour moi.
Si mon père m'écoute, je suis désolée.
À vouloir faire mille choses,
je n’ai finalement pas fait grand-chose.
Rien ne m’a jamais intéressé
et j’ai toujours commencé
plein de projets sans jamais les terminer.
Et à force de ne rien trouver passionnant,
j’en suis venue à me poser la question :
quelle était vraiment le rôle
de ma présence sur cette Terre
et quel était le but de ma vie ?
Alors j’ai fait huit ans comme ça,
complètement perdue
sur le chemin de mon destin.
Et puis j'ai dû rentrer à Ouaga.
Et une fois de retour à Ouaga,
toutes mes angoisses d’enfant ont resurgi.
J’ai dû réadapter ma façon de penser
en fonction de ma communauté.
J’ai dû apprendre le commerce
dans la société familiale avec mon père.
Sans aucun talent dans le domaine.
Et j’ai dû vivre une vie
de femme nouvellement mariée.
Tant de nouveaux rôles
qui s’imposaient à moi.
Et toujours ces mêmes questions:
Qui suis-je ?
Et où est ma place ?
Tout ce que je sais
à ce moment-là de ma vie,
c’est que ce retour au Burkina Faso,
ce retour sur la terre de mon enfance,
ravive en moi ce désir intense d’identité.
Ce n’est d’ailleurs pas pour rien
que l’on dit :
« quand tu ne sais pas où tu vas,
retourne d’où tu viens. »
Avant de continuer,
j’aimerais partager avec vous
cette phrase qui a participé
au changement de ma vie.
À force de se planter, un beau jour,
on devient une fleur.
(Applaudissements)
Oui.
Je crois que si je suis devant vous
aujourd’hui, avec tout mon courage,
parce que je n’ai pas l’habitude
de parler comme ça devant des gens,
c’est parce qu’à travers ce message
que j’ai reçu de la vie,
j’ai compris quelque chose
de super important,
qu’il me semble urgent de crier au monde,
surtout en ces temps difficiles
que nous traversons.
Nous avons tous notre partition à jouer
dans la grande symphonie de la vie.
Il ne faut pas abandonner,
car les épreuves sur notre chemin
sont là pour nous faire prendre
la bonne direction
et pour nous préparer à notre destin.
Finalement, ce qui compte
ce n’est pas mon origine,
ma formation ou le nombre
d’années post-bac à mon cv.
Chacun grandit à sa manière
et à son propre parcours.
Aujourd'hui, je sème les graines.
Demain, je le sais, moi aussi,
je serai une fleur.
On arrive au moment le plus important
de mon intervention.
Là ou finalement, tout ce que je viens
de vous raconter va prendre tout son sens.
Le 9 février 2020,
je tombe par hasard sur un article
de la presse locale.
Gros titres:
« Les Lionnes du zoo de Ziniaré
dans un état catastrophique. »
J’envoie un message à mon mari Julien
et je lui propose qu’on aille sur place
l’après-midi même,
La dernière fois que je suis allé
à ce zoo, je devais avoir neuf, dix ans.
Et à l’époque où “tout allait bien”,
je me souviens d’avoir déjà été choquée.
Donc, on prend la route
ce jour-là avec Julien
et tout le long du trajet
pour aller au zoo,
Je ne sais pas comment vous expliquer
ce qu’il se passe dans mon corps,
mais tout me pousse à faire demi-tour.
Ce n’est qu’une fois arrivée
devant ce portail vert et délabré
qui donne le top départ
de la visite du zoo que j’ai compris.
J’ai compris qu’il m’aura fallu
29 ans pour savoir où est ma place.
Mais toute cette histoire
n'a pas d'importance.
Alma, Donna, Mala et Nala.
Qui sont-elles ?
Ce sont ces miracles de la vie.
Un peu comme moi.
Un peu comme vous.
Un peu comme plein de gens d'ailleurs.
Alma, Dona, Nana et Mala,
et c’est important de dire leurs noms,
sont les dernières lionnes
du zoo de Ziniaré.
Alma nous a quittés le 12 octobre dernier.
Elle avait 23 ans.
Elle était aveugle et gravement malade
et elle représente toute la souffrance
de la vie en captivité.
Le 9 février 2020,
c’est des lionnes dans un état
d’agonie, sur le fil de la mort,
tellement malades et affamées
qu’elles n’arrivaient pas à se lever,
que nous avons trouvées, pardon.
Et si vous me le permettez, j'aimerais
maintenant vous raconter leur histoire.
C’est l’histoire de quatre êtres vivants
arrachés du monde dès leur plus jeune âge,
et de leur habitat naturel,
pour être emprisonnés
derrière des barreaux.
C’est l’histoire de quatre êtres vivants,
oubliés du monde et des êtres humains
et abandonnés à leur sort.
Les lionnes de Ziniaré ainsi que les 47
animaux que nous avons trouvés ce jour-là
sont les survivants de la négligence
et de la cruauté humaine.
Lors de ma première rencontre
avec les lionnes,
j’ai compris deux choses:
la première, c’est que j’avais failli dans
mon rôle de citoyen burkinabé
et de citoyen du monde,
en laissant mourir ces êtres vivants
dans un silence absolu.
La deuxième, c’est que
dans l’atrocité de la situation
dans laquelle je me trouvais,
un miracle s’est produit.
Ce jour-là, j’ai compris
que tout ce temps, je n’étais pas perdue
et que bien au contraire,
je n’avançais uniquement dans le but
de vivre ce moment et de les rencontrer.
Et à travers le regard
des lionnes ce jour-là,
j’ai compris que tout ce temps,
elles aussi m’attendaient
dans l’impossible et dans l’impensable
de la situation.
J'ai réussi à trouver ma voie.
Et comme les lionnes ce jour-là, j’ai
arrêté de survivre pour commencer à vivre.
Les premiers mois au zoo
ont été très compliqués.
Vous devez savoir que ce n’est pas facile
de reprendre un projet
une structure d’une telle ampleur.
Il faut bien comprendre que
quand on est arrivé au zoo ce jour-là,
c’est un zoo abandonné depuis six ans
que nous avons trouvé.
95% des animaux étaient morts
et ceux qui restaient là étaient
dans un état de santé catastrophique.
Ça me fait penser d’ailleurs
à ce couple de porcs-épics.
On est sur le trajet de la visite
et puis on arrive devant
une espèce de maisonnette en béton,
une odeur nauséabonde qui en ressort.
Et là, je tombe nez à nez avec ces être
vivants, ces deux porcs-épics.
Et je vous jure
que j’ai pu lire dans son regard
qu’il me suppliait d’abréger
ses souffrances.
D’ailleurs, le lendemain,
quand on est venu,
on a appris qu’il était mort dans la nuit.
Mis à part les animaux, il y a e
tout un travail à bâtir de confiance,
autant avec les animaux qu’avec les êtres
humains que nous avons trouvés sur place,
les sept employés du parc.
Donc cette confiance a mis beaucoup,
beaucoup de temps à se créer.
Vous devez vous demander pourquoi
j’ai choisi de mener ce combat.
Tout ce que je peux vous répondre,
c’est que je pense
que quand on met son cœur
et son amour dans une cause,
alors nous pouvons faire des miracles.
Je suis persuadée que quand quelqu’un
trouve sa raison de vivre,
cette chose qui l’anime
au plus profond de son être,
alors la terre la plus stérile
peut naître l’arbre de l’espoir.
(Applaudissement)
Hier, il s’agissait d’un zoo abandonné.
Aujourd’hui, ce zoo abandonné
est un sanctuaire en devenir
pour la faune et la flore burkinabées.
Hier, nous avons trouvé 47 animaux
dans un piteux état de santé.
Aujourd'hui, nous avons 70 animaux
épanouis pour lesquels nous nous battons
quotidiennement pour améliorer
leurs conditions de vie.
(Applaudissement)
Le sanctuaire animalier est un espace
en pleine nature africaine
où les espèces emblématiques de notre pays
peuvent désormais prospérer.
En ces temps difficiles
que traverse le Burkina Faso,
le sanctuaire animalier
est un refuge et un paradis
pour les amoureux de la faune
et de la flore burkinabées.
À travers cet espace, nous participons
également à l’éducation
et à la sensibilisation
pour la préservation de l’environnement.
Cela fait deux années consécutives
que nous organisons
des éditions de reboisement.
Des journées auxquelles
nous convions la population
à venir apprendre à planter
un arbre avec nous
et l’importance de planter un arbre.
Un geste solidaire et citoyen.
À travers cet espace,
nous voulons également développer
une zone écotouristique, un lieu d’échange
et de partage des connaissances.
Par exemple, en octobre dernier,
pour la première fois, nous avons réussi
à organiser une mission vétérinaire en
partenariat avec une association française
et une grande structure
animalière internationale.
Mission vétérinaire, grâce à laquelle
nous avons enfin pu apporter
des soins à nos animaux, dont deux
qui étaient dans un état de santé critique
et où nous avons pu échanger et apprendre
avec des gens de divers horizons.
Grâce aux lionnes de Ziniaré,
nous avons réussi à réunir
une large communauté
de personnes différentes
et soucieuses du monde
que nous laisserons à nos enfants.
Car cette aventure est
avant tout une aventure humaine.
Je ne cesserai jamais de le dire.
Seules, nous allons vite,
mais ensemble nous allons loin.
(Applaudissement)
Au début, nous étions deux, Julien et moi.
Aujourd’hui, nous sommes des milliers
à nous soucier du sort
des animaux de Ziniaré
et de l’écologie burkinabé.
D’ailleurs, n’allons pas loin,
sans la mobilisation
de la population burkinabé
à nous soutenir
et nous pousser à réouvrir,
nous ne serions pas là aujourd’hui.
Je suis consciente que si je n’avais pas
été accompagnée et soutenue
par des personnes de tout horizon,
telles que je l’ai été,
je n’aurais jamais été capable
de sauver les lionnes de Ziniaré.
Finalement, on peut dire
que grâce aux lionnes de Ziniaré,
j’ai enfin trouvé le courage de m’assumer
et d’être celle que je dois être.
Et aujourd’hui devant vous,
je peux vous le dire,
mes angoisses d’enfant ont disparues.
Qui suis-je ?
(Applaudissement)
Je m’appelle Chana Husseini,
mais on m’appelle la maman des lionnes.
(Rires)
Il ne faut pas faire ça chez vous,
ni si vous venez au parc.
Je m’appelle Chana Husseini,
mais on m’appelle la maman des Lionnes.
J’ai 30 ans et je suis citoyenne du monde.
Je suis commerçante
dans la société familiale
et présidente et cofondatrice
de l’Association pour la protection
de la faune et de la flore
au Burkina Faso.
Je suis une femme mariée,
mais je suis une femme libre.
(Rires)
Je n’ai pas d’enfants
mais j’ai 70 âmes qui m’attendent
jour et nuit dans leur enclos à Ziniaré.
Où est ma place ?
C’est ici, chez moi,
au Burkina Faso qu’est ma place
et que je décide de prendre ma parole
et de me battre pour mon pays,
pour son environnement
et pour tous
les êtres vivants qu’il englobe.
(Applaudissements)
C’est à travers cet espace
que j’ai l’ambition de créer
une zone de développement touristique,
écologique et économique
bénéficiant à tout un pays
et à toute une communauté.
À toi qui, comme les Lionnes, comme moi,
comme plein de gens d’ailleurs,
a décidé de te taire et d’accepter ce qui
ne correspond pas à ta nature profonde.
N’aie plus peur.
Et souviens toi l’histoire
que je viens de te raconter.
De la boue, nous pouvons faire de l'or.
À cœur vaillant, rien d'impossible.
J’espère que nous, humains
et êtres vivants privilégiés,
trouveront toujours le courage
de nous découvrir nous-mêmes
et d’accomplir notre destinée
au profit de notre monde.
Puisqu'au final, des végétaux aux animaux
en passant par les hommes.
Eh bien, mes chers amis, nous sommes
tous destinés à devenir une fleur.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)